voilà bien bien là bas bien tiens
au milieu du tourbillon de ce métier
entre deux tournages
nathalie prend aussi le temps des choses
de laives il y a bien sûr pilou et lola
deux chats de gouttière qu'elle ne
quitte jamais et puis quelque part dans
le limousin
un refuge loin de tout
j'ai une maison là bas depuis cinq ans
moi ça va devenir petit à petit de
maison
c'est un fait mais c'est un endroit qui
me fait du bien c'est à dire que quand
je quand je tourne pas quand on tourne
dont les tailles beaucoup de gens on est
bon mais quand je tourne pas à paris
c'est difficile de faire la coupure
quand vous n'êtes pas dans le limousin
que vous ne tournez pas à paris que ce
que vous faites
cinéma théâtre et au cinéma joue au
théâtre et puis je fais la cuisine du
reçoit des amis et je me balade beaucoup
j'aime bien me balader
dans les terrasses des cafés j'aime bien
regarder les gens je sais ce que c'est
je trouve qu'ils inspectent la rue c'est
fantastique et c'est merveilleux dans
les gens
[Musique]
tous vos travaux
enfin il y a les a mis beaucoup les
anciens copains du conservatoire
2e prix au conservatoire et saigner
disais qu'elle espérait dans les 2e prix
des trophées carrière moi je te remercie
vous balader le monde au premier
accessit
j'ai dû mérite alors travaillé comme est
l'exception qui confirme la règle
c'est dur qui vous fait une bonne salade
[Rires]
très simple il d'olive avec la cie quoi
vinaigre non parce qu'il ya peut-être
images du soldat
il est sain et sauf iris rencontré qu'un
méchant disons mieux combattre moment
[Musique]